For color textures, we saw that MIP mapping improved the quality of the images
produced. Noisy patterns were blurred out. Normal maps can suffer the same
sorts of problems with noisy sparkles twinkling on and off as we happen to
catch a normal that reflects light directly to our eye. Say we use MIP mapping
on the normal map here to avoid this problem. These bumps describe two ridges.
We average neighboring shading normals to get the next level up. The topmost
MIP map will be a single normal that's the average of all the normals at the
bottom. So, if the object is far enough away, and this topmost level is used,
it will not look bumpy at all. What happens when the surface is far enough away
that MIP level one is used? The ridges disappear, the ridges become twice as
high, the ridges become half as high, or the ridges reverse their directions?